foreign
and welcome to today's webinar
immunodeficient Mouse models to support
prolonged engraftment of human NK and
tumor cells
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by invigo to learn more visit invigo.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Jenna frame PhD senior manager
scientific Communications and marketing
biocytogen Boston Jenna you may now
begin your presentation
great thank you so much Kaylee and to
the team at lab roots for hosting today
and uh to in Vigo for the invitation to
present to you all
so today's presentation will start with
an introduction to the bndg model and
its General utility
I'll then outline the applications of
the bndg mice and second generation
models that were further engineered
based on specific needs for testing the
role of the human immune system in
testing novel immunotherapies these will
include specific case studies
highlighting their capabilities so for
BN to G mice this includes testing
anti-tumor therapies and CDX or PDX
models for the b2mko strain the
possibility of extended studies
involving pbmc derived T cells and
finally the ability of the bndg
humanized il-15 mice to better support
engraftment and survival of human NK
cells for NK based immunotherapies of
course then we'll be able to answer any
questions you may have
so there are a few different versions of
immunodeficient mice out there our bndg
immunodeficient model which was
generated by biocytogen hence the B was
generated on the non-skid background
which is significant to mention because
it has some predilection for being more
receptive of human cells due to known
differences in the mirin Circle allele
and similar to other strains in the
market these mice have a null allele for
prkdc which is involved in vdj
recombination and they also have
mutations in il-2 receptor gamma which
is obviously a key cytokine receptor
critical for development of functional
lymphoid and NK cells
so owing to these additional mutations
compared to the nod-skid predecessors
these mice have a longer lifespan and
minimal incidence of thymic lymphoma
because they have essentially no
lymphocyte leakage which you can see on
the right hand side here um from the
representative data measured by flow
cytometry with essentially no bet or NK
cells present as shown on the top right
furthermore there is no measurable
presence of any IGG or IGM in the serum
of these mice measured by Eliza shown by
the black bars on the bottom right
so together these characteristics allow
for efficient engraftment of human cell
line derived or patient-derived
xenografts
so there are several applications that
these mice can be used for when
engrafted with human cells these include
tumor and tumor stem cell research which
I will focus on today as well as
research involving embryonic stem cell
and IPS cell engraftment differentiation
or functional potential
similarly
um basic hematopoiesis and Immunology
studies are often carried out in these
mice to discover the alterations in
hematopoietic or leukemic cell potential
or transformation potential as well as
in the context of infectious disease
and finally these models can be further
engineered by introducing more human
genes for example to support a specific
human cell population of interest and a
biocytogen we're continually introducing
new specialized humanized models for
these exact purposes
so since our work at biocytogen and in
Vigo is mainly focused on pre-clinical
um immuno oncology studies I will
present applications of these models in
the context of these types of analyzes
so here on the right side is a is a
simple proof of concept study
demonstrating the higher engraftment of
Raji B lymphoma cells into the NDG mice
which is demonstrated by the shorter
survival curve which is shown by the red
line in the panel a
and the drop in body weight in panel B
and significantly higher expansion of
the lymphoma tissue in the bndg mice
compared to the nod skid or the nude
mice counterparts shown in panel C
and on the bottom is evidence of tumor
spread both grossly as well as by
histology in the liver and spleen of
these mice a Scenic party
so when we consider the types of human
cells that we want to graph for testing
novel anti-tumor therapies we can employ
a couple of different strategies
depending on the type of therapeutic
that we're interested in examining so if
we're directly targeting tumor cells we
can simply engraft those into the mice
and test the efficacy of the candidate
therapeutic this could start with a cell
line derived xenograph and move on to
individual patient derived Xenon graft
models and if we're interested in
understanding the interplay between the
human immune system and the human tumor
cells there are a few different
strategies we can employ outlined on the
right side so if we're
[Music]
interested in the role of T cells or
purified NK cells for example
pbmcs can be engrafted directly or for
further purified and I'll introduce an
example a little bit later in the
presentation where we purified NK cells
to do just that
and if the goal is to harness the role
of in the um and or the interplay of
multiple immune cell types then the
engraftment of cd34 positive hscs would
be an ideal choice
so here's an sample efficacy study in a
CDX model where the target antibody is
directly targeting tumor cells so in
this case Raji lymphoma cells that can
be tracked by luminescence activity so
in this study the antibody was given
either at day 10 post tumor cell
injection or on day three and day 10.
with this dual treatment group of mice
shown on the bottom row in panel a
so as you can see from the
representative images and by the blue
curve on the right hand side the animals
receiving both treatments on day three
and day 10 had significantly slower
tumor growth than those receiving a late
treatment or no treatment at all
in this next example injection of car T
cells targeting human cd19 which is
expressed on the same Raji lymphoma
cells were injected into bndg mice two
weeks after the lymphoma cells were
transplanted
and on the right hand side you can see
images of the control and the car T
infused mice over time which
demonstrates a substantial reduction in
tumor growth resulting from the car T
Cell infusion while the untreated mice
which is shown on the left hand side
were unable to survive past three weeks
these CDX studies in bndg mice are also
amenable to multiple different
experimental arms and in this case four
different versions of car T cells shown
on the left hand side in comparison to
the black vehicle controlled mice
so as you can see each experimental
group showed substantially different
tumor growth kinetics owing to the
differential efficacy of these
particular car T Cell populations
and on the right hand side you can see
the body weight of the mice with the
highest tumor burden starts to drop near
the end of the study
so in addition to human tumor cell lines
the NDG mice are also excellent
recipients for human patient derived
xenografts well known as PDX models here
is a summary of all the different types
of PDX models that have been established
with their success rates varying
depending on the tumor type
um notably though all together over 300
different PDX models have been
successfully established in bndg mice by
indigo
so here's an example proof of concept
study demonstrating the successful
engraftment of a triple negative breast
cancer xenograft into the NDG mice with
the tumor growth kinetics shown by the
black line
so the treatment of these two are
bearing mice with kinase Inhibitors
which is shown by the red line was very
effective in blunting the tumor growth
compared with a control group which
proves that the PBX model in this case
can provide a platform to efficiently
evaluate the in Vivo efficacy of
anti-cancer drugs
so in these next couple of slides I'd
like to introduce how bndg mice are
effective recipients for human immune
cells and hematopoietic stem cells
so in these particular in this
particular example human pbmcs were
injected into the mice and
reconstitution was evaluated by flow
cytometry
now as you can see on the the bottom row
with pbmc engraftment the cell type
reconstituted is largely T cells with
both CD4 and CDA T cells expanding in
these mice
however is shown by the reduction in
body weight and survival many of the
mice start to die after five to six
weeks due to graft versus host disease
resulting from the large numbers of T
cells and grafted now despite these
characteristics pbmc engraftment of
these mice can still be extremely useful
for testing T cell immunotherapies that
may not need a long experimental window
for treatment
in addition to pbmc's cd34 positive stem
cells can also be engrafted into bndg
mice now the cons of this experimental
setup is obviously the longer
experimental time window for engraftment
and as well as the radiation of the mice
which is why the uninjected mice which
is shown in panel a by the red line fail
to survive
however the advantage is the
multi-lineage reconstitution of these
mice and as you can see here there's a
high percentage of cd19 positive B cells
as well as
CD3 positive T cells and this
reconstitution can be maintained for
several weeks post-transplantation and
in this study you can see at least 16
weeks
so here is some example efficacy studies
uh for CD3 based by specific antibodies
and bndg mice reconstituted in this case
with human pvmcs
so on the left hand side
um the bndg mice were engrafted with
human pbmcs and then inoculated with
enough C4 gastric adenocarcinoma cells
these mice were then treated with a by
specific antibody targeting CD3 and
claudin 18.2 which showed excellent
efficacy in this model at the higher
doses shown by the green bars
similarly on the right hand side
treatment with linatumumab the CD3 cd19
by specific antibody is very successful
in this humanized pbmc model at
preventing the growth of the Raji
lymphoma cells is shown by the
luminescence data again on the bottom
row
so to provide a brief recap of the
relative advantages and disadvantages of
pbmc versus cd34 positive HSC
reconstitution in immunodeficient mice
um this chart I think provides a very
nice summary so the human pbmc
engraftment is more of a transiently
humanized model uh with overall lower
levels of cd45 positive cells and
grafting with 20 to 30 percent of the
total cd485 population listed here in
the chart
and this occurs rapidly over a period of
about two weeks
however due to the majority T lineage
engraftment gvhd begins to occur in the
mice relatively quickly meaning that the
plan studies will need to be more
short-term and generally targeted toward
T cells
on the other hand the cd34 positive
engraftment model is a more stable
humanized model that requires more time
to establish but results in multi-linear
injury Constitution that is helpful for
assessing agents which require
multi-linear Community or assessing
characteristics like memory responses
however what if you're working on
targeting human T cells and need an
extended therapeutic window to examine
efficacy
um so this need in the field led to the
engineering of a new second generation
model for this exact purpose and this
involves specifically negating the mhc1
response um which on the left side and
left panel you can see is responsible
for presenting endogenous antigens CD at
cells to license cell killing
um so in order to negate this response
um the beta 2 microglobulin region of
MHC was targeted which is shown on the
right side with the green part of the
protein
um however because the beta2
microglobulin protein is a subunit for
both MHC as well as fcrn which is
responsible for binding and recycling of
IGG we needed to get a little creative
with the targeting strategy
so together this led to the following
targeting strategy in these mice to
attempt to reduce the onset of graph
versus host disease in these mice so
disruption of the endogenous beta2
microglobulin allele is shown on the top
right with the addition of that same
cdna into the fcrn locus so it's not to
disrupt the function of fcrn thus we
have a new bntg model with MHC one
essentially disabled so this presents uh
prevents T cells in the graph from
attacking the host cells but allows for
normal presence of beta-2 microglobulin
for IGT recycling
so here shows the experimental
validation demonstrating the lack of
mhc1 expression
um in the bndg b2mko mice shown on the
top row here
um when compared to the parental bndg
strain and and the knots get mice
indicating successful generation of the
mouse model
we also confirmed that MHC Class 2
expression in dendritic cells was intact
um as you can see on the right side in
this case the dendritic cells were gated
by cd11b and cd11c expression and we can
see that MHC 2 expression is unaffected
compared again with the parental strain
and the knots get nice
next we wanted to confirm that the
normal function of fcrn and igg's
recycling can be maintained because the
beta2 microglobulin gene is now under
control of the fcrn promoter
so as you can see in this graph by the
red line the concentration of human IGG
in these mice after injection is
relatively comparable in the KO mice
compared with the parental strain and
the c57 black 6 mice
um but it is not detectable in another
b2mko strain that does not rescue the
beta2m expression in the context of ICT
Recycling and so that's why this strain
is also named B2K
b2mko Plus
so we next tested the engraftment
capacity of pbmcs in these mice using
three separate donors in each column
here
and as you can see by the blue lines the
vndg b2mko plus mice were able to
survive significantly longer than the
parental strain when engrafted with the
human pbmcs from each donor
with a significantly lower incidence of
gvhd symptoms as shown on the bottom row
and each uh for with each donor which
includes signs such as lethargy lack of
response to stimulation hair loss and
and so forth so together these data
allow us to definitively conclude that
the bndg b2mko mice have delayed onset
and reduced severity of gbhd compared to
the B NDG parental strain
here's another sample study with a
little bit longer timeline just so you
can appreciate the extended time window
that this model offers
so flow cytometry data shows comparable
engraftment of leukocytes and T cells
from two separate donors with the green
and the orange from the same donor and
the red and the black
um
and grafted with cells from the second
donor
so
the bndg mice have reduced survival and
exhibit fluctuate
luxury weight shown by the black
increase on the bottom while the V2 mko
mice are able to survive past 100 days
and exhibit no reductions in weight
which would be one indicator of gbhd
that is monitored in these mice
so together this data indicate that
there is indeed an extended pbmc
engraftment window in these mice
next we wanted to test the anti-tumor
efficacy in these mice so in this study
the combination of pembralizumab or
anti-pd1 and epilimab or anti-ctla4 was
assessed against RKO cells which is a
poorly differentiated colon carcinoma
cell line which was engrafted into the
bnag b2mko mice Plus
so as you can see by the green line on
the top left the treatment was very
effective compared to the untreated mice
in which the tumors grew much faster
and on the bottom row we've stratified
the individual tumor growth kinetics to
further demonstrate the clear difference
between the treatment groups
now the average body weight of the mice
is shown on the top left in contrast
remained comparable between the groups
suggesting that there was no adverse
effects of the treatment on the health
of the animals
so the results indicate that this b and
a gb2m mice plus reconstituted with
pbmcs does provide a powerful
pre-clinical model for in Vivo
assessment of Therapeutics targeting
human T cells
for anti-tumor Therapies
so to recap the benefits of the bndg
b2mko model
the engraftment of pbmcs is tolerated by
this model much better owing to the loss
of recognition of mouse antigens by T
cells via mhc1
this significantly extends the treatment
window by several weeks to allow for
more robust experimental results
what about models to test
immunotherapies that involve other cell
types so targeting NK cells to promote
tumor cell killing is a recent area of
interest that is showing a lot of
Promise as is the generation of car and
case for next generation of cell-based
immunotherapies so one key cytokine
regulating NK cell development is il-15
which regulates the activation and
proliferation of the cell population
um so in order to provide a model that
provides support for NK cell survival we
generated a humanized il-15 model that
can be used for engraftment of hscs
pbmcs as well as NK cells directly so in
this model the il-15 cdna was inserted
into the mouse il-15 Gene after the five
Prime utr
expression of human il-15 in this model
was confirmed both by mRNA expression on
the left hand side where the mice were
also confirmed to lack mirroring il-15
expression
similarly expression of human il-15 was
detected from mice simulated with polyic
and this was not detected in Wild type
mice together these data indicate
successful generation of the humanized
il-15 model
so in addition to confirming expression
of human il-15 we also performed some
proof of concept studies to show that
The humanized il-15 Strain better
supports human NK cell engraftment and
maintenance
so in this study the pbmc derived nks
were pre-sorted and engrafted into
either bndg humanized aisle 15 mice
shown by the red dots or the parental
bndg strain shown by the blue dots
so as shown NK cells were able to better
persist over time in the humanized il-15
mice measured both by counts on the top
left and the proportion of NK cells in
the cd45 population shown on the right
in addition as you can see in the chart
on the bottom on the far right nkte
cells do and graft and persist in this
model as well
further phenotypic analysis of the NK
cell cd56 positive populations confirm
elevated expression of functional NK
cell markers and receptors in the bndg
strain containing humanized il-15 such
as granzim B and K g2a nkg2d and nkp46
receptors
and other functional NK markers such as
preference cd-107 and kp30 and cd57
exhibited similar trends
so while pbmcs or NK reconstitution in
these mice can be a useful tool for NK
and T Cell based experiments as
reconstitution is often biased for T
cells with pbmcs engraftment cd34
positive engraftment can also provide
other immune cell types that may be of
interest
so as you can see from the
reconstitution data in this example
engraftment of cd34 positive cells can
also support engraftment of B cells
modest levels of myeloid cells that can
persist for months after injection thus
there are no deficiencies apparent in
the multi-linear reconstitution in these
humanized il-15 mice and they maintain
obviously a significant boost in the MK
cellular Constitution as expected as you
can see on the top right
in this next series of experiments we
show establishment of several CDX models
in the bndg humanized il-15 mice and
grafted with human cd34 positive cells
so after engraftment mice were grouped
and implanted with three different cell
lines depicted on the right hand side
um after this the numbers of leukocytes
T cells and NK cells were assessed
weekly over a period of about five weeks
so as you can see from the red bars in
contrast to the the black bars the
humanized aisle 15 mice showed
significantly higher levels of
leukocytes um T cells as well as NK
cells after tumor song graftment so
these data suggest that the capacity of
the engrafted immune cells is indeed
improved due to the presence of the
human il-15 gene in these mice
in this next case study bndg humanized
il-15 mice reconstituted with cd34
positive cells for six weeks were
subcutaneously injected with human a549
adenocarcinoma cells that were
genetically engineered to express human
clot in 18.2 which is a popular
tumor-associated antigen
um so after seven days mice were treated
with the human anti-claude in 18.2 and a
log antibody regimen
um and this this group is shown by the
red curves on the tumor growth scale
which showed efficacy and slowing tumor
growth compared to the IGG control which
is shown by the black line
so on the right hand side you can see
that
cd56 positive NK cells in CD3 positive T
cells were present both in the blood as
shown in the middle panel as well
um as the tumor as shown on the right
hand side extracted from these mice at
the end point
um and together this this sort of
indicates that this model is is very
powerful for evaluating the role of both
NK cells as well as T cells um and
potentially slowing tumor growth in
combination with other anti-tumor
treatments
so to summarize the utility of this
model
um insertion of the human il-15 gene
really allows higher numbers of
functional NK cells to persist in this
model after
engraftment and reconstitution of cd30
or positive human hematopoietic stem
cells and ultimately this yields a more
efficient model for testing and k-based
immunotherapies
so to summarize everything that I've
presented today
um bndg mice are extremely valuable
pre-clinical research tools used to
assess the functional potential of a
variety of human cell types for a
variety of applications
so they can be engrafted with multiple
human tumor cell lines and primary
tumors for efficacy studies and bndg
mice and for immuno oncology studies the
antig mice can also be engrafted with
human immune cell types to investigate
the role of the human immune system and
in particular these second generation
models are extraordinarily useful so the
P PMC and crafted bneg
beta2 microglobulin KO mice allow for
extended treatment Windows due to the
lack of MIT mhc1 recognition by T cells
and um the cd34 positive engraftment of
the bndg humanized il-15 mice is an
ideal choice for evaluating the NK based
Therapeutics due to the enhanced
survival and Persistence of human and K
cells
so thank you so much for joining us
today and
um I hope we have enough time to address
all the questions if you have any
further questions after the presentation
there's some contact information here
you can contact us at biocyanogen or our
colleagues at Indigo using the
information on the slide and
like to invite Kaylee back to
start the Q a session
awesome
thank you Jenna again for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started we've got a few
questions already in the queue here so
we'll start with this one it asks what
is the difference between the NSG and
nog strains and bndg mice
yeah that's a lot of alphabet soup
um but in general
um
I think the strains are very similar so
the NDG strain is on the not skip
background not obese diabetic
um and further modifications were made
to the il2 receptor gamma Gene
um and so uh I think the strains might
differ in the amount the the type of
genetic editing but essentially the same
genes are disrupted in these nice
thank you next question here are there
special housing conditions required for
maintenance of these strains
yeah so the bndg mice are actually
maintained in normal isolator conditions
um you know we recommend that they
receive acidified water to prevent
bacterial growth but generally they can
live quite a long time in those
conditions
eight
another question here are there any
other bndg stain or excuse me strains
that are going to be available
yeah so um there are several different
uh bndg strains that biocytogen offers
um and you know it really depends on the
type of study that you're considering
and the types of cell types human cell
types that you want to in graft and and
flourish in these mice and so we've
tried to take all those considerations
in mind when we're generating new models
and so if you're looking for a specific
model um definitely reach out
wonderful
all right
well we will go ahead and wrap up there
I want to thank you again Jenna for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor in Vigo for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you had provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event so until next time
take care everyone goodbye